okay let me up follow up about this
YouTube monetization story you may
remember that some time ago I told you
that YouTube rolled out what they called
a new policy of notifying youtubers when
videos do not meet the requirements for
monetization my speculation and that of
others was that actually they've also
restricted the topics of videos that are
eligible for monetization we actually
have a video from earlier this week that
has been deemed not not eligible for
monetization on YouTube that makes no
sense to me will put up a screenshot of
what this looks like an hour video
manager the topic is 911 Widow first to
sue Saudi Arabia under new law and
you'll see on the right side of the
image it says there's a dollar sign
crossed out and it says not eligible for
monetization this is a completely
uncontroversial video it's a video about
a law congressional overrides of a
presidential veto and a lawsuit and my
speculation is that because we're
referencing 911 because we're
referencing Saudi Arabia it was
initially flagged as not eligible for
monetization but we as youtubers have
the opportunity to request that these
decisions be reviewed manually by a real
person which we did and that led to
presumably someone looked at the video
and said well they are talking about a
law which allows lawsuits of foreign
countries and jurisdictional issues
apparently that's a little bit too crazy
it's two adults for monetization on
YouTube this is not about free speech or
censorship YouTube is a private company
I totally get it uh but the argument is
that we've sort of been told that all
that's changed on YouTube is the
notification system when a video has
been d monetized in in a min my
experience doing this for many years
with over 10,000 videos on YouTube
something so milquetoast as this would
not typically be ineligible for
monetization and as a reminder we have a
couple images of the the messages that
youtubers received uh about videos one
saying this is the screen that pops up
when the video is not monetized because
it contains content that may not be
appropriate for ad
vertising you can check this box that
you see which says review my video again
i believe it's advertiser friendly
that's the process and this is a video
from uh philip defranco who put up a an
example of what this looks like and then
we also have another image to show you
which says if any of the above describes
any portion of your video than the video
may not be approved for monetization
this includes controversial or sensitive
subjects or and events including
subjects related to war political
conflicts natural disasters and
tragedies even if graphic imagery is not
shown that's pretty broad right that is
really really very broad even if nothing
graphic is shown even discussing a
political conflict might not be eligible
for monetization fortunately our channel
is doing okay for now knock on wood
knock on loose sight uh and most of our
videos are still monetized but I know
that a lot of people watch the show are
youtubers and they care about this so
that's the latest update on what's going
on there